like right now it's like okay can I sell
out comedy clubs yes yes without ever
doing a stand special I can do it right
and then it's like and then I look at
Theo yeah doing like melbour stadiums I
don't want that you're so likable if you
did that you would start doing like but
I don't want that I don't want to be you
two or Coldplay I want to be fugazi I
want to be fugazi you don't want to be
extra rich or no no no look at look at
but look at look at the little house I
have here right this is my house I have
a great
life you're right you know I'm going to
do one I think it's fear I fear there it
is here here's what it's laziness I
don't want to write a new act you don't
have to you haven't done one so all you
got to do is do all the you've been
doing right it's the best of your first
one I but once I put that out I still
have to write another hour then